bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
penombra black flag episodio 5 penombra
è stata forse la mia primissima serie
che ho iniziato sul canale se non
sbaglio e mi pare che sia proprio la
prima in assoluto quindi ha un valore ha
un valore veramente a questo punto
sentimentale io il mio amico fip siamo
più che amici che cazzo dico comunque
l'avevo l'avevo stoppata come serie
perché avevo perso i salvataggi
semplicemente pian piano diciamo nei
momenti liberi e la sono riportate allo
stesso punto dove vero fermato l'ultima
volta e quindi ragazzi e vision ragazzi
che sono stracontento di poterla
continuare non ne avete idea reca [ __ ]
e allora io nell'arco di quest'anno
scoparsi salvataggi pian piano nel tempo
lì ci ho messo mesi ma sono ritornato
qui
parimenti ragazzi rom rimasti per chi
non ha seguito la storia comunque un po
un casino
non è una cazzata ve la spiego
semplicemente ci siamo persi nei
ghiacciai non chiedetemi come secondo
voi ragazzi che cosa fanno di fare un
uomo che si va a perdere né gli acciai
si va a nascondere in una botola dei tre
ghiacciai e non fa una piega
beh questo è giusto i ragazzi dobbiamo
raggiungere c'è stati matri che mi parla
però non ho capito chi è ha dovuto
attivare il sistema domotico di
sicurezza per sigillarli qui questo
significa che sarà una scheda per
tirarmi fuori un membro del personale o
nolenti ferri ha provato a entrare qui
con una scheda ma non so dove sia finita
quella cosa cazzo ci ha provato senti ho
bisogno di te è la dichiarazione d'amore
le facciamo domani sabbi tiri fuori da
qua ti abbraccerò più forte che mai
ragazzi che cosa non si fa per trovare
un po di fatica
se io mi ricordassi per caso dove devo
andare perché non mi canone non mi
ricordo nulla a parte che eravamo qui
e c'è la pif da qualche parte però non
mi ricordo precisamente dove mi pare qui
se non erro però non vorrei di cagate
dovrebbe allora ragazzi pronti
ecco lo sapevo lo sapevo ragazzi vi sto
per presentare uno degli esemplari più
sexy del pianeta
vi presento pif che è esageratamente un
figo no no no no cazzo lo sapevo che lo
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo che non è
cambiato di una virgola sostanza in un
anno offre aprile forse si chiude chiudi
più ricche o che non ha visto non ha
visto tuca stronzo no ma no kat
e vabbè ma sei bastardo aiuto oggi ogni
[ __ ] nov il no p non è poca e
allora sei stronzo cometa mamma tappato
[ __ ] non lo ricordavo così non me lo
ricordavo fottutamente così dove devo
andare dove devo andare 24 da si apre se
si sia aperta potuta porta è un miracoli
sto gioco io lo dico da adesso in avanti
non si aprirà un cazzo ragazzi
sappiatelo uno abituato dc troppo e
vabbè comunque allora piccola abbiamo
sperato di brutto quindi è una cosa
incredibile adesso che c'è anche un
computer vi se riesco a controllare
notifica ma lo sapevo ma [ __ ]
tu come cazzo le vedi le notifiche più e
la cosa che ancora non lo capite che
cosa ci stiamo facendo qui dentro il
senso io ero ero anche uscito se non mi
sbaglio però non so perché qualcuno ha
fatto i moduli al contenuto di quel
completa rimanesse un mistero ma dai
minchia non me n'ero accorto giuro la
cosa che mi fa strano è che mi ricordo
ancora precisamente come si gioca
è una cosa è assurdo perché questa parte
bloccata non potrà uscire se non sistema
quel coso
cosa percorso cosa il cazzo devo
sistemare fatemi capire a questo no io
allora io indietro non ci torno quindi
evitate di pensarlo lo sapete è chiusa
deve esserci altro modo per entrare i
condotti ragazzi mi è venuta un'idea
però voi non dovete invitarlo a casa ok
ci provo non sono sicuro e ma ci provo
ok non ha funzionato un cazzo perfetto a
io torno indietro ma se qualcosa mi
salta addosso mica quanti schiaffi non
avete idea
comunque devo trovare perfetto non c'è
più questo è già un vantaggio come cazzo
si usano le pile che non mi ricordo alle
tracce perfetto nicchia ragazzi non mi
ricordo più nulla può che ho visto una
luce
ho visto una cazzo di luce facciamo
finta di niente allora questa non si
sposta questo è murato a queste
mastrolindo non serva un cazzo ragazzi
non lo so non sarà pip calma calma calma
perfetto non c'è una casa ma vi sta
prendendo per il culo
no no non mi sto prendendo per il culo
apri apri
sì sì sì ok chiudi chiudi più di più di
merda che non sei altro c'è un ansia
addosso che non avete idea ragazzi
comunque siamo dove dobbiamo andare come
fece allora già che ci sono ste cose
squarciate ma guarda non avete i dati
non sono sono tranquillissimo giuro non
potrà essere più tranquillo perché cazzo
c'è una ciotola non me ne frega un cazzo
basta che usciamo di qui dato certo
minchia pesanti le lasagne se riuscissi
ad andare avanti senza che nessuno mi
salti addosso che crisi è ok ho visto la
luce
ovi store e non è molto meglio magari
più interessante decisamente ragazzi e
allora per caso devo illuminare il
corridoio del canale troppo buio
perfetto ragazzi a sono d'accordissimo
non ce n'è non c'è veramente ombra di
dubbio
voglio capire perché lui continua ad
avere state ok ci penso di posti brutti
sono perché ci sono le mani sul muro non
è una cosa cos'è che è successo qui non
lo so sarà passato al bambinoni degradi
non ne ho idea ragazzi che cosa che ho
visto uscire la stipula sia ma vicino
per sé sia stato un animale ma non ci
sono segni gli artigli c'è un altro
verme della madonna spero di no comunque
devo ancora capire perché cazzo siamo
qui dentro perché ci sono delle forme a
terra regala le orme non l'avevo visto
non è normale allora noi andiamo di qua
perché l'unica strada che mi pare giusta
sia si apre si si apre grazie a dio sì
sì sì ma c'è cosa per salvare grazie
ragazzi
non ci vogliono un ansia quando gioca
sta roba che non avete idea ma non
importa
andiamo avanti lo stesso ma dubito che
io ci riesca effettivamente che cazzo
su ad un genio come ancora non ma dove
cazzo sto andando lega ma dove cazzo sto
andando e tra questi non c'erano prima
ragazzi questi non ci ama siamo in
un'altra stanza ok allora bay cannellini
che vestiamo allora che bello ragazzi
che è bello ma quindi le orme sono degli
animali ma dito cazzo cazzo
ok ok ok ok cani per era finto quella
merda bene così e allora fate mica
allora ci sono dei cani che sono morti
perché le sue orme sono i cani io non
avevo capito a sta cosa
sì perché ovviamente esterne che
sembrano molto umane fanno un genio mi
chiamavano sherlock ragazzi insomma non
importa di me si siede giorno che bella
giornata di merda
anche per lei o fai una giornata normale
noi sia 10 con gli amici di baby 2 brt
cadono i cadaveri in testa e non è
l'ormai che poi da dove cazzo è caduto
ragazzi che non ci sono buchi sul
soffitto si può che grazie a dio così ma
mi sento chiamata ok ok ok veloce veloce
sì sì già devo farmi già tutti in corsa
tutto il corpo
sapevo me la devo fare in corsa in poche
parole c'è però non ho capito come
allora io vado qui ok ok ok non ti
spegnere
si ok che si ragazzi impossibile non ce
la posso fare
michael si è una cosa è un'impresa
assurda sì sì sì
bye bye bye bye cazzo si si si
buongiorno lo so che una giornata di
merda lo è anche per me non rompermi
tuoi doni a ragazzi non so come cazzo ci
sono arrivato qui assurdo e assurdo
pazzo e cos'è ho trovato scala ho
trovato la [ __ ] scheda che all'esito
di quello che di serrature vecchio sulle
ma [ __ ] alle serrature vecchio
stile guarda quanto è figo sta tizia
dovrei farmi tutto grandissima ragazzi
ciò dobbiamo rifare tutto non c'è non
dovevo cantare vittoria mi sa e lei
vai cos'è ciò posso far agazzi input non
è impossibile non è fottutamente
impossibile ce la posso farmi che se
corro in inizi si si accenni 10 accenti
di [ __ ] vai così fai così vai così dio
santo che sudata ragazzi è stato
pazzesco trasferisco magari non farli
uccidere la fif
nel mentre che torna indietro sono
abbastanza contento si trova adesso c'è
la schiena ragazzi posso andare a
trovare la tizia è la casa perché devi
farlo un per nicolò dagli assicurati sta
parlando è semplicemente nella mia c'è
flo che non è non è un tizio che potevo
arrivare dalla tiziano mi rompere i
[ __ ] non mi rompere i [ __ ]
io non posso avere un ansia così mentre
gioca non si può avere un ansia così
caso come faccia come faccio ora passare
come infilai stop idoneo cosa come ma ti
stai mangiando la porta 6 ruotando
liberamente che si fa miccini che in un
bidone che però ricordi per tutta la
vita a bastardo
cosa cazzo sta facendo no no no vi fu
una piece of i [ __ ] sei un testa
di minchia ragazze ragazze ma scoperto
sto dentro figurino passarlo
come ha fatto ok ok è la entra ma vaffan
corsa ora testa la testa di covers
consultate di fare come come penso che
non sia ma la smetti di correre madonna
che il caso 6 usain bolt
no mi sono chiuso mi sono chiuso con un
[ __ ] mi sono chiuso con un coesione
affatto rapito ok però fermato
effettivamente qua nell'ultimo episodio
di penombra si è chiuso da solo il suo
gatto non fate commenti mussi mac
d'estate lettore accettato scheda si si
era quello che cazzo inserita la non
c'era un lettore dove non la metto non
l'ho messa prima perché non c'era nulla
dunque cazzola primo a va bene ragazzi
abbiamo aperto la porta non chi non
chiedetemi come non lo so cazzo cazzo
cazzo ragazzi siccome non voglio andare
più avanti nel gioco mi limito a pulire
basta dove devo andare di qua non avete
idea di che cazzo di sollievo ciò ne sta
ma stai scherzando
no ma tu stai scherzando grazie ragazzi
e ragazze o qualcuno devi morire e devi
morire atrocemente stronzo devi morire
atrocemente cosa sono sti cosi cosa sono
sti cosi sei uno stronzo di merda ha
ucciso ragazzi dove stiamo andando
perché ma perché
ma perché ma perché si apre sta merda
non ci credo più
mason sanzioni non possono venire così
tieniti store anno fa qualcosa hai mai
preso un bidone in vita tua
adesso se adesso signore
quanto sei figo da una liegi in me lo è
sparito lega c'è una ragione valvola
cielo valvola qualcosa serve a qualcosa
serve
io ho tantissimo timori ma quel bene
esattamente [ __ ] ok non mi ha
preso la mia traghetti bello che poi non
mi prende i ragione di ragioni non so
che cosa ho fatto
non so che cosa ho volutamente fatto
ragazzi ho schiacciato scrive ai
ragazzini che posso concludere qui
l'episodio è veramente ragazzi penombra
nonostante sia passato un anno e
pazzesco è come se ci giocarsi per la
prima volta è assurdo e non era neanche
come non ricordava ancora peggio quindi
michia non vedo l'ora di coltivarlo
perché sarà spettacolare come lo è già
stato finora e con che ragazzi fatemi
sapere che cosa ne pensate prossimo
episodio uscirà tra pochissimo comunque
è ragazzi come al solito sei video è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche afasia di facebook e come ogni
video trovata nella descrizione del
senso prestiti iscrivetevi ci mettiamo
nel prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]